quand un enfant doit être soigné à
l'hôpital un des principaux défis c'est
d'atténuer sa douleur qui peut
accompagner certaines interventions la
science a beaucoup évolué dans ce
domaine ces dernières années et au chu
sainte-justine de montréal on a mis en
place une initiative tout en douceur
[Musique]
la glace a fait partie du quotidien à
l'hôpital c'est vrai qu'on peut à la
limite traumatisé un peu un enfant que
même sa famille quand on fait pas
attention à cette douleur procédurales
là
on rend pas le travail et à l'hôpital
pour faire mal à des enfants mis les
personnes qui a l'intention de faire du
mal à des enfants
[Musique]
de voir un enfant qu'on doit t
immobilisé qui vient tout temps soir
tellement hélas malsaucy c'est vraiment
une procédure qui me rend heureuse de
mon travail
[Musique]
il ya des gens qui pensaient c'était une
croyance dans le domaine médical local
et les tout jeunes enfants ne ressentait
pas la douleur
longtemps on se dit bon ça durera pas
longtemps ça fait pas mal ce mec qui
sort ou leur peau comme ça en voyant ça
dure quelques minutes même si ça dure
quelques minutes
sao des répercussions importantes après
c'est sur le parcours de soins
[Musique]
si on prend mal en charge de la douleur
lors d'une procédure payer une mémoire
de la douleur une anxiété qui peut être
accru dans les procédures qui suivent au
final ce qu'on souhaite le plus c'est
que chaque intervention douloureuse soit
fait avec les bonnes techniques pour
gérer la douleur pendant l'intervention
[Musique]
ce qui nous manque c'est de les
appliquer toujours au quotidien cette
équipe en bonne respiration la coop
qu'anticipé des titres ok c'est vraiment
important pour nous cliniciens qui
travaillons à l'hôpital de s'assurer
finalement que ses connaissances là sont
connus aussi des équipes médicales sur
le terrain c'est pas juste dans la
littérature puis dans la recherche mais
on se les approprient finalement puis
après ça on s'assure que nos équipes
médicales les mettre en application
[Musique]
et
à chaque jour je lis des articles génie
des publications je crée un réseau avec
les autres courte et de connaissance ici
à montréal mais aussi à travers le
canada
mon rôle dans tout ça je vais les
rencontrer les équipes avec le reste de
notre équipe tout doux pause de leur
demander quelles sont leurs besoins
qu'est ce qu'ils ont déjà sur le terrain
c'est quoi leurs questions et leur souci
sur les nouvelles pratiques qu'on veut
instaurer et d'ensemencer ça c'est
vraiment un accompagnement personnalisé
que je fais avec les équipes
[Musique]
un de nos plus grands défis et la
résistance au changement certaines
personnes peuvent être réticents à
vouloir utiliser ces nouvelles pratiques
dans leur quotidien auprès de leurs
patients parfois ça peut être parce que
l'enfant est très malade par exemple on
veut pas perdre de temps le s'assurer
que ce soit fait rapidement et peut être
aussi une idée mal conçus que si on
prend le temps de soulager la douleur ça
va être beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
long beaucoup plus contre qui ce qui en
fait pour le corps le changement de
culture c'est sur ces c'est crucial dans
cette histoire là
pour contrer cette résistance là on doit
vraiment juste être à l'écouté des
personnes qui ont une réticence au
changement on doit se mettre dans leur
environnement dans leur contexte ils
vraiment comprendre d'où vient cette
résistance là pourquoi il ya une
résistance et faire aussi preuve de non
jugement donc on doit vraiment juste d
écouter comprendre lorsque leurs
questionnements leurs soucis parce que
ils ont une manière de faire mais c'est
vrai que ce n'est pas toujours la seule
manière de fois
[Musique]
et on va voir papa de ce côté là tsonga
roquettes part
d'enfance qui étaient démontés comme
efficace c'est l'utilisation de sucre à
une concentration quand même très
concentré c'est entre 24 et 30 % donc on
à divers fabricants comme le nôtre des
fêtes à partir de de sirop d'érable donc
c'est un produit québécois en plus qu'on
utilise qui est vraiment médicale
donc on va utiliser le sucrose pour
l'installation du soluté de du petit
bébé on donne une minute avant la
procédure savent albi produire des
endorphines ça va avoir un effet
vraiment dans le soulagement de la
douleur
il va tt l'astuce ou doit sa mère puis
vraiment voir un super bel effet pour le
soulagement de la douleur avec un public
souvent qui va presque pourrait sentir
pour réagir à la procédure
pour diminuer la douleur pendant la
pause de sept bébés oiseaux communs de
ces crèmes pour la peau l'autre chose
qui est utilisé sur une date assez
régulière c'est une crème analgésiques
et non qu'on peut appliquer sur la peau
puis qui vont geler la peau de manière
superficielle et donc les enfants qui
ont des interventions avec des aiguilles
vont ressentir beaucoup moins de douleur
finalement parce qu'on a gelé la peau de
manière superficielle
[Musique]
avec quel poupet on va jouer d'attaquer
aujourd'hui
évidemment il ya tout ce qui est les
stratégies psychologie qui est de
préparer au mieux un enfant avant sa
procédure avec un vocabulaire simple
adaptée à son développement on écoute
tout cas
oui la douleur qui est très importante à
gérer mais il ya aussi l'anxiété qui est
générée par cette situation médicale là
et qui souvent va faire en sorte que
l'enfant est très stressée mais aussi ça
va potentiellement et la douleur
finalement et tout cela fait en sorte
que c'est une expérience de soins qui
peut être désagréable
[Musique]
c'est pas ça la vie beaucoup d'anxiété
par rapport à ces procédures la
[Musique]
menace
peut on a essayé c'est sur la
distraction qu'on essaie avec beaucoup
d'enfants les deux le téléphone des
écrans on a essayé ce qu'on appelle le
grand mage et qui est une technique un
peu entre l'hypnose puis
l'autosuggestion où on essaie de
suggérer aux passants qu'on lui met un
gain qui va lui enlever la douleur mais
rapidement après une ou deux fois il y
avait compris que finalement le gadget
mais y était peut-être pas aussi magique
que sa fille n'était pas capable de
garder la visualisation jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
la commune
c'est fini on le fait sur un psychologie
dont il voit une psychologue fiona qui
essaie de l'aider à cheminer la dent
puis effectivement depuis quelques mois
l'on voit tranquillement pas vite une
amélioration parce que si vous trouviez
qui pleurait le mouvement il ya eu une
époque où c'était des coups de pied et
bouger c'était c'était pire que ça
voudrait avoue m c'est vraiment bon je
suis à fort comme dans le lien avec
qu'il met entre vos jambes pour que vous
soyez confortable coussin est capable de
rester immobile aussi pendant la
procédure une des choses qu'on peut
faire pour diminuer la douleur qui est
assez simple si c'est le positionne si
on s'assure que le parent soit dans la
salle avec l'enfant si on demande à
l'enfant de s'asseoir sur le parent
peut-être ou d'être en position assise
ce qui est déjà eu un sentiment de
contrôle qui est beaucoup plus important
qui accouchent et immobilisé déjà il ya
une nette amélioration de cette
sensation donc c'était là qui peut être
provoquée par l'intervention et donc on
le sent plus à l'aise on sent moins
inquiets et on va arriver avec le début
de l'intervention douloureuse beaucoup
plus rassuré que si on était en perte de
contrôle totale coucher immobilisé sur
une table
memon
c'est hyper important de préparer les
parents aussi à ses interventions là
parce que c'est vrai que la manière dont
le parent va se sentir face à
l'intervention va beaucoup tenté la
manière dont l'enfant va se sentir
qu'ils peuvent être un soutien important
pour leurs enfants mais il faut qu'ils
soient inspectés adéquat aussi il faut
donc essayer de coacher un petit peu les
parents dans le genre de discours à
utiliser le genre de comportement
utilisé avec leurs enfants pendant
l'intervention pour que eux-mêmes arrive
à rendre sur rassurant pour leurs
enfants
[Musique]
j'avais vraiment p
on vient d'engager une éducatrice en
milieu pédiatrique en anglais china life
spécialistes ici à l'urgence qui est
dans le fond ici pour aider les familles
à traverser des moments difficiles
qu'ils vivent ici à travers leur
parcours hospitalier que tu es prêt pour
te coucher et pour qu'on commence oui
championne donc les stratégiques
l'éducatrice en milieu pédiatrique peut
utiliser avec les patients et les
familles d'abord il ya la distraction
donc tout ce qui rentre dans le jeu tu
peux utiliser la musique les vidéos
évidemment qu'on en fonction du tronc à
tout coup toutes ces méthodes là mais le
feuilleté de
d'apprendre plus sur toutes les
stratégies qu'on peut utiliser pour
minimiser cet inconfort l'os cette
détresse loge chez l'enfant et rend la
pratique de la médecine beaucoup plus
agréable est ce que tu veux toucher
c'est moi
pour nous tous c'est un projet qui est
gagnant pour tout le monde pour nos
soignants pour les professionnels
pour les familles avec qui on travaille
surtout pour les enfants 1 c'est plus
agréable pour l'enfant mais c'est aussi
plus agréable pour le soignant de voir
qu'on a réussi à rendre le soin moins
désagréable qu'on enfants quand on a une
amélioration de la qualité des soins on
a des soins des fois qu'ils se font plus
rapidement parce que l'enfant coopèrent
mieux puis après ça aussi vaut mieux
coopérer le lendemain quand on veut
faire une intervention peut être
douloureuse également parce qu'ils
auraient eu une expérience plus positive
la veille
[Musique]
est ce qu'il reste du chemin à faire oui
définitivement il reste du chemin à
faire mais on est dans la bonne
direction éventuellement dans un avenir
que j'espère pas trop lointain tout le
monde va être hyper conscientisés à ce
sujet l'homme puis on va au revoir que
ces présents partout dans l'hôpital sur
une base vraiment quotidienne pour tous
les patients
lorsque tu étais une championne je
rêvais d'être
[Musique]